mr. president it is my pleasure to
extend a warm welcome to you and mrs.
Liu on behalf of our entire community we
are deeply honored that you have chosen
to visit Yale your country has an
ancient tradition of reverence for
education and your actions affirm this
tradition during the past decade you
have made massive investments in your
University's strengthening the most
excellent of these institutions while
broadening access to higher education
from less than 5% to more than 15% of
your college-age population your
nation's focus on education has
contributed substantially to your
historically unprecedented success in
lifting more than 200 million of your
citizens out of poverty in the past
quarter century we admire these
achievements and like most Americans we
are hopeful that the development of your
economy will be accompanied by continued
expansion of the rule of law and
strengthening of the rights of
individuals these past two summers Yale
has been privileged to host Presidents
and vice presidents from 14 of your
leading universities for an intensive
two days seminar on the policies and
practices of the world's most respected
institutions our conversations have
acknowledged deep differences on
important questions of values and
national policy but we hold the common
belief that only through education can
one acquire the capacity to think
creatively and independently and thus
contribute to scientific and material
progress
well as to the humanistic and artistic
expression that enriches society we also
agree on the power of personal encounter
to deepen mutual understanding among
those who start from different
traditions norms and values our
experience mirrors that of thousands of
US and Chinese scientists and scholars
and tens of thousands of students whose
interactions with one another can be a
foundation for a lasting peace between
our nation's
Yale's proud of its extensive
collaborations with China scholars from
our Faculty of Arts and Sciences and
faculty from nearly all of our
professional schools are currently
engaged in more than 80 research and
educational collaborations with Chinese
counterparts in addition to our seminar
for university leaders we're currently
involved in training programs for your
environmental officials mayors senior
executives of state enterprises and
senior governmental leaders we're
collaborating with Fudan and Peking
universities on major scientific
research programs and with your alma
mater
Ching hua University on both cultural
and environmental projects our China Law
Center directed by Professor Paul Gertz
who helped to orchestrate the rule of
law initiative launched by presidents
John Ziemann
and Bill Clinton is deeply engaged with
your cut with your courts your law
schools your administrative agencies and
the National People's Congress helping
to advance legal reform and the rule of
law
our American students are eager to learn
about China they learn from study
enrollment in our first-year Chinese
language courses increased by more than
50 percent this year
and each time professor jonathan spence
offers his course in modern chinese
history over 300 students enroll and our
students learn from encounter from
getting to know the more than 600
Chinese students and scholars currently
in residence here at Yale who teach even
as they pursue their own studies we look
forward to your address mr. president by
your presence today you honor the long
association between Yale and China and
you honor the place of the University in
both Chinese and American society we are
deeply grateful mr. president
changing that mr. Richard Levin
president of Yale University
dear students and faculty members ladies
and gentlemen let me begin by thanking
you mr. Levin for your kind invitation
and the opportunity to come to Yale to
meet young friends and teachers of this
world renowned University come into the
Yale campus with its distinctive
academic flavor and looking at the eager
young faces in audience I cannot but
recall my great experience studying at
Tsinghua University in Beijing 40 years
ago
indeed what happens during one school
years will influence his whole life
I still benefit greatly from the
instruction of my teachers and my
interaction with other students Yale is
renowned for its long history unique way
of teaching and excellence in academic
pursuit if time could go back several
decades I would really like to be a
student of Yale just like you
Yale's motto light and truth which is a
calling for human progress represents
the aspiration of every motivated young
man and woman over the past the three
centuries Yale has produced a galaxy of
outstanding figures including 20 Nobel
laureates and five American presidents
the words of Nathan Hale an American
hero and Yale a luminous quote I only
regret that I have but one life to lose
for my country
end of quote have also inspired me and
many other Chinese I sincerely hope that
Yale will produce more talent and
contribute further to the social and
economic development of the United
States and the cause of human progress
ladies and gentlemen dear friends the
Chinese and Americans have always had an
intense interest being and courage
deeply about each other
the Chinese admire the pioneering and
enterprising spirit of the Americans and
their proud achievements in national
development as China develops rapidly
and a steady headway is made in China us
cooperation more and more Americans are
following with great interest
China's progress and development
understanding leads to trust today I
would like to speak to you about China's
development strategy and its future
against the backdrop of the evolution of
the Chinese civilization and China's
current development endeavor I hope this
will help you gain a better
understanding of China
in a history that spans more than five
millennia the Chinese nation has
contributed significantly to the
progress of human civilization but its
cause of national development has been
an torturous one in particular in a 160
years and more since the opium war in
1840 the Chinese people have fought
courageously and unyieldingly to rid
themselves of poverty and backwardness
and to realize national rejuvenation
thus profoundly changing a destiny of
the Chinese nation 95 years ago the
Chinese people launched the revolution
of 1911 that overthrew the feudal
autocracy which had ruled China for
several thousand years and opened the
door to China's progress fifty-seven
years ago the Chinese people succeeded
in winning liberation after protracted
and hard struggle and founded new China
in which people became their own masters
28 years ago the Chinese people embarked
upon the historic drive of reform
opening up and modernization and have
made phenomenal progress through our
remitting efforts between 1978 and 2005
China's GDP grew from one hundred and
forty seven point three billion u.s.
dollars to two point two two five seven
trillion US dollars
it's import and export went up from
twenty point six billion u.s. dollars to
one point four two to one trillion US
dollars as foreign exchange reserve
soared from 167 million u.s. dollars to
eight hundred and eighteen point nine
billion u.s. dollars during this period
the number of his poor rural population
dropped from 250 million to 23 million
the above review of the profound changes
in these 160 years shows one thing
namely by carrying out persistent and
hard struggle the Chinese people have
both changed their own destiny and
advanced the cause of human progress on
the other hand I need to point out that
despite the success in its development
China remains the world's largest
developing country with per capita GDP
ranking behind the 100th place the
Chinese people are yet to live a world
of life and China still faces daunting
challenges in its development endeavor
therefore it requires sustained and
unremitting efforts to transform the
country and make life better for the
people in the next 15 years we will
strive to make new progress in building
a moderately prosperous society in the
all-round way that will benefit China's
one billion and more population
we aim to raise China's GDP to four
trillion US dollars by 2020 averaging
$3,000 per person by then China's
economy will be better developed this
democracy will be further enhanced more
progress will be made in science and
education as culture will be further
enriched and the society will become
more harmonious and people will lead a
better life to realize these goals
China has adopted a new concept of
development in line with its national
conditions and the requirements of the
times that is to pursue a scientific
outlook on development that makes
economic and social development
people-oriented comprehensive balanced
and sustainable we will work to strike a
proper balance between urban and rural
development development among regions
economic and social development
development of man and nature and
domestic development and opening wider
to the outside world greater emphasis
will be put on addressing issues
affecting people's livelihood overcoming
imbalances in development and resolving
key problems that have occurred in a
course of development who will pursue a
new path to industrialization featuring
high-technology
good economic returns low resource
consumption low environment pollution
and food use of human resources
we will bring about coordinated economic
political cultural and social
development
and we were endeavor to ensure
sustainable development by boosting
production improving people's life and
protecting the environment this concept
of scientific development is based on
experience China has gained in its
modernization drive and put forth in
response to the trends of the times
it is also rooted in a cultural
heritages of the Chinese nation the
Chinese civilization is one that has
continued uninterrupted
for more than 5,000 years the distinct
cultural tradition of the Chinese nation
that developed in the long course of
history
has exerted a strong influence on
contemporary China just as it did on
ancient China putting people first
keeping pace with the times maintaining
social harmony and pursuing peaceful
development these values that are being
pursued in China today are derived from
its tradition but they also give
expression to the progress after times
the Chinese civilization has always
given prominence to the people and
respect for people's dignity and value
centuries ago the Chinese already
pointed out that quote people are the
foundation of a country when a
foundation is stable the country is in
peace end of quote quote nothing is more
valuable in the universe than human
beings end of quote
the ancient Chinese emphasized the value
of serving the people enriching them
nourishing them and benefiting them
we are pursuing today a people oriented
approach towards development because we
believe that development must be for the
people and by the people and its benefit
should be shared among the people we
care about people's value rights and
interests and freedom the quality of
their life their development potential
and Happiness index because our goal is
to realize the or one's development
after people ensuring the right to
survival and development remains China's
top priority we will vigorously promote
social and economic development protect
people's freedom democracy and human
rights according to law achieve social
fairness and justice and enabled the 1.3
billion Chinese people to live a happy
life
the Chinese civilization has always
given prominence to unremitting
self-improvement reform and innovation
as an ancient Chinese motto puts it
quote as heaven keeps vigor through
movement a gentleman should
unremittingly practice self-improvement
and of quote
throughout is 5,000 year history it is
thanks to their perseverance
determination stamina and innovation
that the Chinese nation has grown after
surviving numerous setbacks and
adversity the Chinese people have shown
and rising spirits in reform and
opening-up
creativity in national development and
great tenacity in overcoming
difficulties and road to progress and
all this gives expression to the spirit
of unremitting self-improvement embodies
in China's cultural tradition the
Chinese civilization has always given
prominence to social harmony unity and
mutual assistance back in early days of
the Chinese nation the Chinese always
advocated that quote harmony is most
valuable and of quote they strove for
harmony between man and nature among
people and between the body and the soul
and yearned for an ideal society where
quote everyone loves everyone else
everyone is equal and whole world is one
community and if quote today China is
endeavoring to build a harmonious
society it is a society of democracy and
rule of law fairness and justice
fraternity and integrity vitality and
stability order and harmony between men
and nature
it is a society where there is unity
between the material and the spirit
democracy and the rule of law fairness
and efficiency and vitality and order
the Chinese people takes the maintenance
of ethnic unity and harmony as their
bounden duty and the defense of the
country's sovereignty and territorial
integrity their sacred mission any act
that promotes ethnic harmony and
national unity will receive the warm
welcome and support of the Chinese
people on the other hand any act that
undermines Chinese ethnic harmony and
national unity will meet their strong
opposition and resistance the Chinese
civilization has always given prominence
to good neighborliness the Chinese
nation cherishes peace in foreign
relations the Chinese have always
believed that quoted as strong should
not oppress the weak and the rich should
not bully the poor and live quote and
advocated that quote all nations live
side-by-side in perfect harmony and of
quote the Chinese held that quote one
should be as inclusive as the ocean
which is vast because it admits hundreds
of rivers and of quote and called for
drawing upon the strengths of others
today China hosts hide the banner of
peace development and cooperation it
pursues an independent foreign policy of
peace and commits itself firmly to
peaceful development it seeks to
accelerate its development by upholding
world peace the world peace is in turn
enhanced by China's development China
firmly perceives a strategy of opening
up for mutual benefit and wing wing'
outcomes it genuinely wishes to enter
into extensive cooperation with other
countries
it is inclusive and is eager to draw on
the strength of other civilizations to
pursue peace and development through
cooperation and play is part in building
a harmonious world of enduring peace and
common prosperity ladies and gentlemen
dear friends China and the United States
are both countries of vast territory
where many ethnic groups coexist and
different cultures intermingle both our
two peoples are hardworking and talented
due to different historical backgrounds
and national conditions there are
differences between China and the United
States but this enables us to learn from
each other and draw on each other's
strengths closer china-us cooperation
serves the fundamental interests of our
two countries and peoples and is also of
far-reaching significance for peace and
development of the whole world vast as
it is the Pacific Ocean has not stood in
a way of exchanges in cooperation
between our two peoples over the past
200 years and many moving episodes of
mutual learning and mutual help between
our two peoples who represent different
civilizations have been recorded in 27
years since the establishment of
diplomatic relations in 1979 china-us
relations have maintained steady
momentum of growth despite twists and
turns on the way bringing tremendous
benefits to both countries and peoples
entering the 21st century the world has
continued to undergo profound changes
peace and developments remain the
calling of our times and the other hand
factors causing instability and
uncertainty
are increasing and new challenges and
threats are looming against this
backdrop the common interests between
our two countries are increasing and the
areas of our cooperation widening global
peace in a security now face new
challenges such as fighting
international terrorism preventing the
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction protecting the environment
and human habitat and combating
transnational crimes it is exactly in
these fields that we share important
strategic interests China has a huge
market and its development has generated
a strong demand while the United States
has advanced technology and high quality
products this has created enormous
opportunities for economic and technical
cooperation between our two countries
indeed there is a broad prospect for the
growth of constructive and cooperative
china-us relations in all fields
yesterday morning President Bush and I
had an in-depth exchange of views and
china-us relations and major
international and regional issues of
common interest and reached the broad
and important agreement we are both of
the view that the two sides should
approach our relations from a strategic
and long-term perspective and that we
should enhance dialogue expand common
ground increase mutual trust deepen
cooperation and promote the or ones
growth after constructive and
cooperative china-us relations in a 21st
century when we focus on the overall
interests of china-us relations respect
and show understanding to each other I'm
confident that our relations will move
ahead in a healthy and a steady manner
and contribute to the well-being of our
two peoples and bring greater hope to
people around the world ladies and
gentlemen dear friends
a composer cannot write enchanting
melody with one note and a painter
cannot paint landscape with only one
color the world is a treasure house
where the unique cultural achievement
created by people of all countries are
displayed the culture of a nation tells
a lot about the evolution of the
nation's understanding of the world and
life both past and present culture thus
embodies a nation's fundamental pursuit
of the mind and dictates is norms of
behavior the historical process of human
development is one in which different
civilizations interact with and enrich
each other and all civilizations in
human history have contributed to human
progress in their own unique way
cultural diversity is a basic feature of
both human society and today's world and
an important driving force for human
progress as history has shown in the
course of interactions between
civilizations we not only need to remove
natural barriers and overcome physical
isolation we also need to remove
obstacle and obstruction of the mind and
overcome various prejudices and
misunderstanding differences in ideology
social system and development model
should not stand in a way of exchanges
among civilizations still less should
they become excuses for mutual
confrontation we should uphold the
diversity of the world enhance dialogue
and interaction between civilizations
and draw upon each other's strengths
instead of practicing mutual exclusion
when this is done mankind will enjoy
greater harmony and
happiness and the world will become a
more colorful place to live in ladies
and gentlemen dear friends exchanges in
culture and education and among young
people serve as a bridge for increasing
mutual understanding between our two
peoples they are also a major driving
force for the healthy and stable growth
of china-us relations Yale is a
forerunner in conducting china-us
educational exchanges and provides an
important platform for cultural
exchanges between our two countries 156
years ago a Chinese young man named Rome
home entered yelled campus four years
later he graduated with distinction and
received a Bachelor of Arts degree
making him the first ever Chinese
graduate of an American University later
group after group of young Chinese
followed his footsteps and studied in
Yale over the past 20 years
Yale has admitted over 4,000 Chinese
students and undertaken more than 80
cooperation projects in culture science
and technology and education with China
last summer
Yale sent the first group of students to
China for internships and some among
them became the first foreign interns to
work with China's Palace Museum I wish
to take this opportunity to express my
appreciation to miss Levin and Yale for
the efforts you have made to promote
exchanges between our two peoples to
enhance mutual understanding between
young people and educators of the two
countries I announce with pleasure here
that we have decided to invite 100 Yale
faculty members and students to visit
China this summer
I'm sure you can look forward to an
enjoyable experience in China ladies and
gentlemen dear friends as an old Chinese
saying goes as in the Yangtze River
where the waves behind drive on those
before so a new generation always excels
the last one young people represents the
hope and future of the world they are
full of vitality new ideas and
creativity I sincerely hope that the
young people in China and the United
States will join hands and work to
enhance the friendship that our two
peoples and together with people of
other countries create a better world
for all thank you
mr. president thank you so much for that
enlightening speech for for explaining
China's recent development in terms of
its history and for expressing such
optimism about the future of China's
peaceful rise we we're especially
grateful for your marvelous gift of 100
invitations to faculty and students and
we I know that many of our students and
faculty will take this up with great
delight so thank you so much
to see tension concerning can't either
Shanghai h-here warfare hyung causing
him to need a Jumbotron da da da da
língua assured our Hadouken Newton God
gene deletion of the far turn he's in
into a woman Nyong'o Quincy way lighter
look one what yo G concerning same woman
far treaty and allowing Romani by
association had Josh ratta yelled us to
yell - it out wrong virtue or songs in
common we Honduran fate hung young yada
sin Randhir shown in Tecate excuse me
for forgetting that we moved to a
sequential translation at this point
boh-chan well one we since I woman guy -
I own it outright mr. president were so
pleased that you've agreed to answer a
few questions which members of the
audience have submitted in writing to
see a young woman fate hung causing the
journey anyway Dottie I wouldn t CC
attention woman that teens on show me
and each other
I have asked Ernesto Zedillo the
director of Yale Center for the Study of
globalization and the former President
of Mexico to select and present to you
some representative questions um more
seeker what you are talking TN yellow
tasha change hawaiian children seem to
rent the do Shan Shan Shan tiga when T
is an integer
president who president Lavigne ladies
and gentlemen we have received 78
questions showed our cheetah bhagwanti
and of course I do not intend to read
all of them because you have to travel
mr. president
what are ample you got you got that
teach will I let you a watch without
Nene oh yeah you're told but I will give
these questions to your patola
that would be good at us take to study
with that Cheney news I drew a woman
should I pay her causing woman
concoction see you will be a great
professor wait I woman that's your
condition cut a [ __ ] fatal gives you
the chouchou
many of these questions have common
topics jolliness you don't want this
issue we're out here comment on the
truth here but I have chosen some of the
ones that I have found to be
representative of them what you tell a
gigolo relationship ito your type I'm
single so let me star anise Terp
resident there is much discussion and
little agreement in this country the
United States about what China
represents for the United States some
people see in China a threat others see
an opportunity
some people describe China as a
strategic adversary other people think
of China as an a strategic partner is
there agreement in your government mr.
president about what the United States
represents for China hey babe what woman
you took a tree trunk or do you make
what you weigh - Amma seokwon find the
talent that should be open door to the
eager the song fire-maker Yossarian when
run away from bush league away she goes
here in children way from LA she lets
you go Syrian children waitron washer
make or the eager channel to show radio
another in your language from washer
make other chains either Chandler who
cut open so you what you sang Venetia -
sure Saito go Chung for me man your
mouth home young that you put on the
easier may without either John go away -
Amma - should I take her shoes for
father that she tantrum maybe I should
come on president CEO is an old friend
of mine
ha can touch is a good tablet a jeweler
Korea t-shirt is egg of India Wharf in
Han yang kita God totally de I'm more
than willing to answer this question
raised by him on behalf of all of you
can hear what a yin yang dong-geun were
using hand oh okay girl Havana some good
chance to Tala eto hope him father at
all to me when I change I change
attentively to me him choosing reason
coach answer issue more father the
fattened on Putin Cassandra me the
sample to back woman can certainly
choose to defer in very essential change
the way whose they are hoping switching
come father as I said in the speech
delivered just now ever since China's
reform and opening up China has embarked
on a path of peaceful development on the
domestic front
China has focused on economic
development we have concentrated our
energy and resources wholeheartedly on
economic growth and we have also tried
to constantly improve the lives of the
Chinese people in the development
process and the external front China has
always pursued a independent foreign
policy of peace and we have always tried
our best to safeguard world peace and
promote common development are Subhan
Allah
some gotta gingy's away father
she said she'd Allah underwritten you
Tongo de Jing Zhi Susheela
Nanjing Bevins Judy Anderson job putting
Caribbean Latin golem in the meaning
here we see a taffeta chavala poverty
over the past 28 years it is indeed the
truth that China's economy and society
have registered tremendous achievements
on an average basis China's economy has
grown by nine point six percent a year
and this has changed the fate of the
Chinese people and indeed this has also
presented a valuable opportunity for the
growth of the world at large
that's a woman in the condo she ransom
Buddha cornea to attention as the tongue
go your sangjun tell her you got you
data sources your societal though we see
you gotta see these being said we must
see that although a speck China has
become comparatively speaking stronger
it still has a population of 1.3 billion
any figure no matter how large it is
divided by 1.3 billion will become a
small one
well can't hurt Honda son gotta engine
kinesin handsome
hi Gio agent Shiva me test jacket and oh
hi Patti I really hope women's items
easily frightened items and and oh hi
gender - Adama Adama venti g armament
you don't English society insa woman ah
filter she WA yo u Co hurting that Katya
winding as I said in the speech the per
capita GDP of China now stands at nearly
one thousand seven hundred US dollars
making China ranking behind the one
hundreds place in the world in the
process of economic and social
development we also encounter many
complex problems and difficulties we
need to concentrate our energy and
resources on resolving those problems
and meeting the challenges that's why we
hope to see a peaceful international
environment to home some golden jaunty
she changing Buddha so hurting father
doll tunga dhwaja bukiyou na young :
yep ok Rishi Jen : - muah - father
Cecilia cocoa fight under poverty
rameshwar her today she to her to Dakota
in the future China will continuously
stay firmly on the course of peaceful
development China's development will not
compromise the interests of anyone nor
will China's development threaten anyone
China's development actually will
present valuable opportunities for the
growth of other countries as well and
China always stands ready to become
partners of peace with other countries
see to me why she
varam a Tamilian go to cydia geo to me
are you John ago job the reverse
geocoding switching Coonan father for me
so many on go to a chair for the to me
auditorium as for the china-us
relationship first China and the United
States are countries of significant
influence in today's world in both
countries show the important
responsibilities for world peace in
common development - indications - are
so many Angora CEO Huang van de
Kooning's and indeed against a new
international backdrop China and United
States share extensive common strategic
interests woman yang Gor
ji young guys bu guava Korean guys
cherishing the kotatsu our two countries
should should not only be stakeholders
all the more we should also become
parties of constructive cooperation
Sanjana what is a compa eating potato
Quan Dada to marry me whom a human
de-tension
who young who I'm sure this view of mine
was certainly win the support and
endorsement of the Chinese people and
the American people
Thank You mr. president
although you honor me with your
friendship and I admire you a lot I have
to make a harder question to situation
concerning urges Suren means power tons
of money Oh what kind of photography
sing - wha - Co 17t katana with other
with the impressive economic growth of
by China over the last quarter of a
century would be unthinkable without the
economic freedom brought about by
reforms initiated in 1978 by the Chinese
leadership there is always the question
of whether or not a system that allows
economic freedom while restricting
political freedom will encounter serious
problems of social unrest in the long
run is this a concern for the Chinese
government does the Chinese leadership
have a strategy to enhance human rights
civil liberties and religious freedom in
China
Lindgren Cuomo's young Honda citizen
John Rogan mail today
ito jibanyan from walling Darren fatty
the chintakaya Shabaks leader my boy
chanting when did she question Shanxi
yoga teacher rogash initio Jing Zhi trio
- at home sure your year so 200 G oh
wait wait ow Cheeta Yin Tong - away
pawan thing - Chung you - okay pointing
the wente gesture photon watching for
secuence in the ER when Tina
crumbling down cheorung yomo Yohey girl
- it's her like Kai Shang Lin Chen took
her her Minchin her tongue shouts Leona
the way as you are said in this change
inaccurate even to the server we also
had a witching I also shared hope that
when raising a question my friend will
give no mercy to me
Tan's Maradona was either we wouldn't
Warren we changed something Jen to the
father you're seeing King GT through
Fidelio Joe to be frank with you I'm a
materialist I'm accessed actually I
believe that actually the development of
the political infrastructure must be
compatible with the economic foundation
well yeah anyway maoming to kill me Oh
Jennifer I also believe there is no
modernization without democracy
Desna rubaba
dongho our Japan la king jesus answered
you descend Yeo Jin Jin Qin Qiong go to
Mission large entities at a kegger
Teixeira saputra meander yes
Oh wonderful horses either but I don't
think it is a factual approach or fair
to say that the economic and social
achievements China has scored over the
past 28 years are merely attributing to
the economic reforms
Tommy Chobani you know Chum go fishing
la paga Chincoteague Uyghur 1030 Geiger
learn what is Geiger then charming guy
go the fact is that since the Year 1978
China has carried out reforms on the
economic political cultural and other
France
faster the tunngle your PDR similarly
audio didn't - wait that's what the
energy you know who knows that in GT is
a Geiger family has a density to the
Ganga famiiy don't go to $3 soon we are
tango for someone who have a more
in-depth understanding of China he will
he or she will easily come to the
conclusion that built in the field of
economic reforms or in the field of
political restructuring China has indeed
scored important achievements I return
la zonga Jing ji cilicia we're so far
Tanner's yep yummy - mwah densities the
cheap and she tongue gorging G fatale -
really
and I think of the past more than 20
years the sustained and rapid economic
development in China in in itself has
demonstrated the fact that China's
political system suits his economic
development - hua hua man yin yang Kang
Joo gyeong goda coaching her tumble and
in the year
Gigi went water treating sensitive guy
girl father
so we're dreaming - in the future who
will continue to make efforts in the
lighter of China's national conditions
and the will of the Chinese people to
actively prudently and appropriately
move forward the political restructuring
and develop a socialist democracy
women chanting e po Fong foo Ming Zhu -
in Kota coming Yoshida since the time
your sister Eva recorder family pardon
to me Eva shushing min to changing means
with her mean to granny
means gender in the future we'll
continue to make efforts to further
enrich the formats of democracy and
expand the orderly participation in the
political field by our Chinese citizens
and we are also going to further
implement the strategy of running a
country according to law
we'll continue our efforts to ensure
that the Chinese citizens could better
exercise their rights of democratic
election democratic decision-making
Democratic management and democratic
supervision as provided for in the law
well may you ajj very bullets into the
change today you're eating yet down
woman poke we thought back leg or
attended suit or demotion on one hand we
are ready and willing to draw upon the
useful experience of foreign countries
in field of political development on the
other hand will not simply copy the
political models of other countries